me and my fiance we've been together for
about six months seven months and uh
well she has some court dates coming up
and she's facing some time she's facing
about eight years now I don't know if I
should I mean I really don't know what I
should do should I should I break it off
before she goes or should I wait for her
for eight years or or what should I do
man I mean I really really love her
she's a really good woman and uh we have
a lot of good times together man but you
know I'm a man and not only because I
have needs because it's not even about
that it's just about the you know I mean
that's a long time to wait I mean she
might not do a full eight we should
probably do I don't know maybe two three
four five years bang Debbie gang baby
crime you know
and this is this is a crime call
you know and this is where hopefully she
got with Morgan and Morgan over there
they do good attorney work
I don't know who she got getting her the
years or getting out of them or whatever
but um
uh
I'll say this man first of all how the
times have changed
this is a call you would hear during war
war one
World War II World War III
when people
when wives their husband going off to
military or they're in A POW Camp what
do I do they call in
you know on the ring phone in the D you
know what do I do do I wait for Andy
do I wait for Ricardo
I mean look it depends on what type of
life you want to lead
There's Something Beautiful about
waiting for someone
there's something romantic about it
there's something really perfect about
because you get to keep them in this
space in your head where they're perfect
they can't really do any wrong because
they don't have to it's almost sometimes
waiting for somebody can be a sense of
control
I'm gonna wait for you but really what
I'm doing not all the time
but really what I'm doing is I'm going
to say I'm going to keep this in a
perfect place where it's manageable
because I don't really have to interact
with it
it's almost like something I can just
keep on the shelf right here I can
communicate with it when I need to I can
get what I need from it
in some ways I have somebody to care
about but I don't physically have to
have them there
I'm not saying you're doing that I'm
saying I've done that in my life in
relationships
um
but damn dude but then also you have to
do them conjugal visits or whatever or
you have to sneak over there at night
and just Andy do frame your weiner
through that chain link fence
and let uh your girl let Molly or
whatever her name is over there not you
know knobby off over there for the
spotlight hits you
because I can't ejaculate under a sheer
Spotlight anything over probably
120 watts buddy I can't come you know
and that's who I am
but if there's a strong if a you know if
I'm getting an HJ and a boat pulls up or
something you know or
uh
or if they have two even two coal miners
walk up while I'm getting a handy bro I
can't
I can't eat Jack around more than
probably about 120 watts
of straight light
so
but that's me you know that's me and I
think it's Brave now then how far do you
want to go
do you want to make her stuff and mail
her things do you want to have an apron
also because I'm sure there's a whole
club of men
who love prison women let me look it up
men who love prison women
couldn't oh
um
let me see husbands of in prison
women
they kill their husbands now in prison
that's not you man because you're
calling in
um
I don't know I get it you know you I'm
sure you could get some information
about this uh but look I think it's
admirable of you
you know man used to go off to War and
the women would wait for him
you know and I think if you're baby
birds over there in prison
you know and you you can keep your seed
in the feeder
then yeah you can wait till she gets out
you know
and then also you may be able to set up
a situation with her where you say look
I'm gonna I'm gonna date
I love you and this is I'm gonna date
you while you're there so then at least
you also can be honest with her in case
you want to date outside of there you
give yourself the opportunity to still
fall in love you know
um
because then you don't want to have a
thing I don't think where you're
cheating and having to lie about it
that's this that's when you're skating
on dirty ice baby but praise brother I
hope you uh you know I think it's really
kind of you to even think about that and
I think it shows some awareness for who
you are as a person and I think
as long as you're honest with her about
what you're thinking bro that's really
going to be nice you know and so bless
you man and good luck over there
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one